as long as you love it you have to keep
going you cannot quit maybe one day
somebody does throw you a bunch of money
and you can stop sleeping in your office
or maybe it's just a slow grind up and
it takes you 10 years to become an
overnight success you'll never know how
long it will take you to be successful
but what you do know is that if you quit
on something that you love you will end
up regretting it for the rest of your
life as long as you love it you have to
keep going you can't quit I would rather
no one fail than not know because the
things that you regret are rarely the
things that you do it's the things that
you didn't do the things that you had a
chance to do you had an opportunity you
thought about it you felt it but then
you back down because you're afraid
those are the things that you regret if
you don't have the love anymore for the
thing that you're in you need to move on
because you will never create great
things doing work that you don't love
you're going up against people who
success hey it's Nina Carmichael and we
made these videos because you're
probably the most ambitious person in
your circle but you know you're capable
of more and you need to push by
surrounding yourself with the best so
today let's learn from one of the best
my husband Evan Carmichael and learn to
stop being afraid of what other people
think enjoy
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one overcome the fear of farrier the
biggest fear we have isn't failure
you're not afraid of failing the biggest
fear we have is of failing in front of
other people you're afraid of people's
judgments the reason why we stay stuck
the reason why you still are where you
are is because you're afraid of other
people's opinions you have
great ideas inside you you have great
ideas if you're watching this video
You're subscribed to this channel you
have great ideas you know you're capable
of more you know you want to serve you
know you want to help
and great ideas are flowing through you
and we shut them off
shut them off because we find a logical
reason why we can't do it right the
logic reasons in our head are well the
timing's not right or I don't have the
gear right on the connections or uh you
know I'm in the wrong country or
whatever logical excuse that we come up
with that's that's listen it's based in
reality it's actually based in fact
because you wouldn't you're a smart
person you wouldn't believe a stupid
reason
so the reasons that we're listening to
are actually based in some kind of fact
but they're still an excuse and
underneath it underneath that reason why
you can't do something is because you're
afraid
you're afraid I'm afraid we're afraid of
taking the next step and the fear
underline that is not the fear of it not
working out it's the fear of it not
working out and who's going to see you
you were so tied up into what other
people think about us that we'd rather
play small for life than actually go off
and accomplish and risk failing in front
of other people we're so afraid of that
that we never go off and
chase our dreams down and you're stuck
in this mental exercise of what you
could do
and then never actually doing anything
my biggest fear of disappointing people
you know it's that still fear of
judgment it's still fear of I'm gonna
show up and speak in an event and it's
just not going to go well that that
people will
be unhappy with my speech and I put
a crazy amount of pressure on myself and
in my head I think people are here and
if I struggle then the whole thing is
ruined right I remember I was speaking
at printable shards event and uh it was
in Puerto Rico and people are paying
tons of money to be here you know it's a
30 to 50 000 Mastermind and everybody's
got giant businesses right these are
multi-million dollar businesses owners
who are in the house and there's a
multiple Day event I think it was a
three-day event and I'm I'm speaking for
one of them not even a whole day I'm
speaking I have one I've got an hour or
something of time right at that event
in my head it's if I suck on stage then
people will freak out and be unhappy and
say this was a total waste of event
we're really
really tiny nothing part of this event
this event Char the scene Dean graziosi
the C the other speakers there if any
one speaker sucks I mean if Brendan
sucks that's a big deal because he's
speaking for 80 of the time if I suck
for one hour nobody's really gonna care
nobody's really gonna be asking for a
refund but
even though that's the the actual answer
it's not the it's not the thing that's
in my head and that's what we need to
fight that's what we need to fight
because I used to say no to
Opportunities because I was really deep
down just afraid that I would not be
able to deliver
I remember that I used to secretly hope
people would cancel on me
I would I would secretly hope that
interviews would cancel on me that
meetings would cancel on me
um I remember I would book something out
like it's two months in advance right I
don't know if this has ever happened to
you this this makes sense or if it's
happening to you let me know in the
comments
I would book something out that was a
month in advance or two months in
advance and so yeah I'm like that's
exciting I'd happy to do that and then
on the day of I'd look at my calendar
and say oh that's coming up and I would
secretly hope I would check my email I
remember would be checking my email
hoping that that person would cancel on
me to say oh I'm busy or I got sick or
it's not going to work out anymore and
let's reschedule and I remember I check
in the morning and I check two hours of
four and check an hour before and check
half an hour before and check 10 minutes
before like if there was no email then
then I would go ahead and do it
so I'm losing insane amounts of
productivity right like how many times
am I checking my email before this thing
happens lose an insane productivity and
also not actually serving right not
actually living my mission my message
not not actually being proud of myself
for what I'm doing and it it almost
always worked out like I never had an
interview or a meeting or something
where I just massively underperformed
and actually sucked right that that
never really happened but I was always
afraid of it happening
and so I had to teach myself
this is this is what I want to do like
the only thing worse than me not doing
this
is is me doing this and canceling right
or them me never doing an interview and
me never doing a meeting
and just recognizing that it was just
fear talking and again the fears of me
disappointing people and feeling in
front of somebody else
I'm sitting here filming in in the car
Nina just came back we love you Nina
Nina's uh doing some grocery shopping
and I'm filming here you know in the car
we got the dogs here in the back seat
timo's chilling and this used to make me
afraid you know that look there's a guy
who just pulled up next to me
she's not watching but in my head you'd
be like this guy's watching
you have to be afraid of filming in a
parking lot be afraid of filming uh
walking down the street I'd be afraid of
filming with my sister in the room you
know you should be afraid of all of that
so what is that
it's just fear of other people's
opinions why am I afraid of this guy
why I'm afraid of that guy I don't know
that guy right
why am I afraid of him and his opinion
first off he doesn't even care right
he's not even looking at me he doesn't
even care maybe he'd never even noticed
that I was filming period right so we
think people care they don't care
on the off chance that he actually cares
uh maybe he is judging me and thinks I'm
crazy holding this camera up with with
the tripod in my hand maybe he thinks
I'm crazy great uh if somebody's leading
with that then then they hate their own
life like if somebody's leading with
just negative judgment he's got his own
issues to deal with that have nothing to
do with me or maybe he's inspired maybe
maybe this guy goes look he pulled out
his phone maybe he's making his own
YouTube video maybe he's inspired maybe
that guy is now going to be the next
YouTube sensation let's go
so we assume that everybody's gonna
watch us everybody's only looking at us
and
and we're gonna disappoint and be a
giant failure and everybody's gonna
laugh for me to kill us right like
that's the thought that's that's in our
head where the reality is most people
don't care
most people right like 90 of people
don't even care
five percent of people might judge you
and they're in a really negative spot
themselves and the other five percent
maybe they're inspired by you and they
see that and they go and do something
with their life
but you playing small and listen to that
fear instead of actually taking some
kind of action will always lead to a
negative spot like you know that you
could do more you want to do more you
want to serve on a bigger scale but
listening to that fear
instead is keeping you stuck this is one
of the biggest problems for
entrepreneurs is that you you have all
these great ideas that are flowing
through you right you've got you've got
an endless list of ideas how big is your
list of things that you could do that
you get excited by when you look at them
and then how many are you actually doing
well not very many you're missing the
momentum because at the end of the day
you could write down a list of all these
reasons why it can't work out and and
when the timing is going to be just
right and perfect right I'll start this
on January 1st or start this next month
or next week or Monday or on my birthday
or some artificial day you come up with
some reason of when you should be
starting this thing right but if you
actually examine it if you actually took
a little step back and looked at your
goals that you haven't hit that you
haven't started that just remain an idea
and you've never taken momentum on if
you actually took five minutes to step
back from it create a little distance
and look at them and look at your list
of reasons why you haven't started
really it's just fear
and when you can catch that
that's when you make a life-changing
decision
because as long as you are
not chasing down the things that you
want to do because you're afraid of
somebody else's Judgment of you as long
as that is a thing that rules you you
will never win you will never accomplish
anything great and you'll you'll live
life with regret so even now my my
biggest fear is still disappointing
people
and the ongoing challenge is to catch it
and when you can catch it and when you
can know BS
catch it to say I'm just throwing up a
bunch of excuses but really I'm just
afraid when you can catch it
then
some of the courage to go to the
difficult thing summon the courage to
say I'm gonna I'm gonna take this fear
head on
because as long as that fear runs your
life
you stay stuck
and every time you catch the fear and
you do it because of not just feel the
fear and do it anyway Feel the fear and
do it because of
you start to teach yourself to be a
little stronger a little more courageous
and you move a little bit closer to
becoming the person that you are capable
of being rule number two do scary things
doing what you are afraid of is your
path to success every time you take on
something new that scares you that
pushes your comfort zone that requires
you to stretch on the other side of that
scary thing is the new you who is now
capable of more most people they shrink
from scary things
because they're scary but if you want to
win if you want to hit your ambitious
goals then you have to teach yourself
that you do scary things so I recently
came back from two pretty significant
speaking gigs uh in my career as I'm as
I'm building up and speaking on bigger
stages the first was when I was speaking
of Brendan burchard's event and it's his
growth.com event and Brendan one of the
greatest speakers in the world invited
me to come and talk to his group of
couple thousand people and then I went
to Ed mylett's event just recently in
Whistler and this is a smaller group 100
so people but they pay sixty thousand
dollars a year to be a part of his
program and so they're coming to learn
from the best he sandwiched me between
David Goggins and Peyton Manning so it's
David Goggins and then me and then
Peyton Manning that was the lineup and
so
when I was backstage at the Brendan
event
I remember moments before going on stage
I was the most scared that I'd been in a
long time the most nervous and most
anxious I was afraid of disappointing
people my biggest fear is letting people
down my biggest fear is that I'm gonna
let Brendan down and Dean grazios who
they both brought me there and I was
just gonna suck on stage that was my
biggest fear and so I had a mini panic
attack backstage five minutes before
going out but I have this mini panic
attack and I'm forgetting what I'm gonna
say I I imagine myself going on stage
and just blanking out
and I tell myself I'm Evan Carmichael I
do difficult things I love difficult
things if I don't do difficult things
I'm never going to accomplish great
things so I have to do difficult things
I love it I thrive on difficult things
and then I remembered what I was gonna
say and then I went out and I did my
thing
and now when I went to Ed's event
I wasn't as nervous I wasn't as afraid I
was still scared I was still afraid of
letting down at my left letting down
Andy frisella who they both brought me
there
being between David Goggins and Peyton
Manning and just being out Shawn uh you
know everybody knows them they may not
know me all of it all of the fears and
doubts but less than what I had at
Brendan's event not because it wasn't as
big a deal but because I had just done
it because speaking on Sage a couple
thousand people at Brendan's event and
having that panic attack and getting
through it
changed Who I Was Made Me Stronger made
me more capable of doing the next thing
and the next thing was Ed's thing and so
if I hadn't gone to Brendan's I would be
terrified going to Ed's thing
so every time you take on these
difficult challenges
you might have the panic attack you
might have the anxiety inside you might
have that little voice to say you can't
do it what if you fail what if you
disappoint people what if you lose
respect what if it doesn't work out
but you know what's worse you know
what's worse than going up and failing
not trying
not doing it
finding some reason finding some excuse
to say you're sick you're busy you can't
make it but in the back of your head
you know you're just afraid and the last
thing you want to do is teach yourself
that when you are afraid that when you
have an opportunity in front of you and
you're afraid to do it that you say no
you don't want to teach yourself that
you teach yourself the opposite that
when you're afraid that when there's
something in front of you that you want
to do but you're scared you're anxious
you're worried about letting people down
that you jump in
and you say I'm all in because I do
scary things so how do you do it I'm
going to give you a three-step process I
think will help step number one is ask
yourself if you could not fail
if you could not fail what would you do
what would you do just blue sky you know
you're not going to fail what would you
do
for me I'd be speaking on bigger stages
I'd be speaking more often be speaking
on bigger stages and and that's now
become even asking that question sets
into motion action right now now my goal
is to speak on two stages a month and so
traveling to speak on two different
stages every month and putting that plan
into action for the next six to 12
months right if you knew that you could
not fail what would you do
eliminate the risk of failure right
eliminate because that's how we'll
default back to like I'd love to do that
right but I might fail but this is going
to happen then you get back into
negative small thinking mode
for for two minutes forget about that
stuff
for two minutes let yourself dream again
then imagine if you could not fail what
would you do step number two expect to
fail
expect to fail expect to suck especially
if it's your first time if it's your
first time speaking on stage for example
you're not gonna be great you're not
going to be less brown you're not going
to be Tony Robbins you're not going to
be Brenda sharp you're not going to be
great it's your first time your first
video you're not going to be great it's
why I kept my first video up on my
channel too you can go back and watch it
the first time you do it you're not
gonna be great this is one of the
biggest fallacies in human thinking is
we expect to be great the first time we
do something and if we're not great we
don't do it anymore
as kids we learned that when we fail we
get up and we try again as adults though
we're so terrified of failing that we
don't try most things and then we have
this constant thought in our mind that
we know we're capable of more but we're
too afraid to go up and start and so
expect to fail Step One is know that
you're not going to fail great that
gives you the freedom to dream to do the
thing you actually want to do and not
get in your own way anymore with your
thinking but step two is then you expect
to fail
micro not macro right if you keep going
if you keep doing it you keep making
videos you keep doing your speeches you
keep reaching out you're gonna win but
the first time expect to fail reduce the
expectation that your first time of
anything has to be amazing and then step
three is tie yourself forth to the
effort so many people tie their self
forth to the result instead of the
effort right did I give a good result
did I give a good speech did I give a
good video did I get a result from my
customer I did it did it work did I win
that race did I XYZ right you're tying
your self-worth to the result what you
want to do is tied to the effort so that
even if you go up on stage and suck
you tell yourself I'm the best
I did it when I look back at my Brendan
video
um at his event
I could have done better I can always do
better I look at it and as even though
people loved it and sent Innovation at
the end and and Brendan was freaking out
and he loved it I look at that and see
all the holes all the all the places
where it could have been stronger could
have had more energy could have been
better
and if I was doing that speech in a
smaller group
it would have been better if I was doing
that speech just to a camera with nobody
in the room it would have been way
better because I would have been able to
practice it over and over and over again
until it was perfect but I'm really
proud of the effort
I was five minutes ago before going on
stage freaking out having an anxiety
attack forgetting everything I was gonna
say in front of this massive audience
and I went out and I did it and so I'm
proud of my effort that's what I want
for you too you have some big ambition
you let go with the fear of failing
you then expect to fail
you expect to suck at the beginning and
you tie your self-worth and you pat
yourself on the back even if you failed
even if you stopped even if it sucked
and you say I did it I tried I tried my
best because every day you woke up and
you tried your best I promise you you're
gonna get amazing results also to make
sure you're actually taking action after
watching this video I've designed a
special free worksheet just for this
video the worksheet will highlight all
the Lessons Learned in this video as
well as pull out our three favorite
learnings and quotes that will inspire
you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there rule number three never quit on
something you love as long as you love
it you have to keep going you cannot
quit maybe one day somebody does throw
you a bunch of money and you can stop
sleeping in your office or maybe it's
just a slow grind up and it takes you 10
years to become an overnight success
you'll never know how long it will take
you to be successful but what you do
know is that if you quit on something
that you love you will end up regretting
it for the rest of your life as long as
you love it you have to keep going you
can't quit so look at my story it wasn't
easy being an entrepreneur growing up
that's why I do so much to help
entrepreneurs because I don't want you
guys to struggle as much as I did in my
first real business when I was 19 I had
to decide between earning a hundred
thousand dollars a year and traveling
around the world in my dream job versus
owning 30 of a company making 300 bucks
a month and being unsure if anything's
gonna work out or not and I decided that
I had to keep going I had to try because
I didn't want to end up being 85 years
old looking back and said I never did it
I never went for it I would rather no
one fail than not know because the
things that you regret are really the
things that you do it's the things that
you didn't do the things that you had a
chance to do you had an opportunity you
thought about it you felt it but then
you back down because you're afraid
those are the things that you regret
that's what you regret most I didn't
want that to happen
but starting off my business wasn't easy
I struggled I suck I made it harder on
myself because I told my friends that I
was living the entrepreneur life and I
couldn't hang out with them meanwhile
that twenty dollars was just too
expensive for me to go out and have beer
with them
I isolated myself and made myself lonely
I felt worthless as a human being and
the worst day of my life came when I
told my business partner that I quit on
him that it was just too difficult that
I couldn't keep going that I needed to
feel like I was contributing that that
my time meant something that all this
work I was putting into something I just
need to feel valuable again that I was
contributing to something
because when you wake up every day and
you're working and it's just not getting
results it can be real hard to keep
going
and so I told him that I quit I hung up
the phone and then just started crying
and the next day I woke up and I just
thought I can't I can't I can't quit on
this not yet I haven't given everything
I've got
because I felt like
in a year and two years and five years
in 20 years I would look back and regret
that I gave up
if I knew that I gave everything I had
and it didn't work out I was okay with
the failure
it was just an idea of that thing
lingering that I could have given a
little bit more that I still like this
thing and I needed to see it through and
I and I didn't that I quit on it I knew
that would eat me up forever
and so I had to get up that next day and
tell myself I'm not gonna quit yet
I just have to find a different way to
stand what I've tried so far has not
worked it has not worked I'm making zero
money well 300 bucks a month
but it's not working out and I hate
myself I hate my life I hate how I feel
about myself I have to find a different
way to stand
and that energy allowed me to keep going
that energy allowed me to then ask
myself who else has done this before and
I looked at Bill Gates and how he
started Microsoft and that started the
path up for my business and then two
years later I sold my company it
happened pretty quick
all because I refused to quit on the
thing that I knew I needed to see
through so how do you do it I'm going to
give you a three-step process for you to
follow that I think will help number one
is you quit when you don't love it
anymore and I think people often even
stay in things for too long I think
people have fallen out of love with
things and they stay with it because
they don't want to be seen as a failure
I think a lot of entrepreneurs stay in
their businesses for too long I think a
lot of people stay in their
relationships for too long because you
don't want to be seen as a failure for
quitting on things if you don't have the
love anymore for the thing that you're
in you need to move on because you will
never create great things doing work
that you don't love you're going up
against people who love doing the thing
who love it you're never gonna win
you're never gonna have success
meanwhile you deserve to be doing work
that you love because you could be the
Michael Jordan at something else
and so stop thinking your way through it
stop singing to wrap your head around it
you don't you need to wrap your heart
around it
ask yourself are you excited to go do
this thing do I still love doing this
work
and if the answer is yes then you have
to find a way to keep going you have to
go one more day one more day one more
day and if it's no then you have to get
out immediately ASAP stop spending your
time doing work that you don't love
step number two is flip patience and
impatience you gotta flip patience and
impatience most people are very patient
with themselves and inpatient with the
results you want results today where are
my results let's let's go where are my
results I wanted to happen why is it
happen fast enough right the
entrepreneur mindset but you're patient
with yourself
I'll do it tomorrow I'll get started on
that thing on Monday uh you know start
of the next month you know what next
year January 1st that's where I'm gonna
hit a heart you need to flip that
that mindset will destroy you you have
to flip it you flip your patients with
impatience instead what you want to do
is be patient with the results you're
patient with the results you know that
you have a big goal it's going to take a
little bit of time to get there
if you have any goal that's worth
anything you're not going to accomplish
it today
that's a tiny little goal
you're worth more than that you're
chasing down Big Dreams
but you need to be more impatient with
yourself you're patient with the results
and inpatient with yourself that you
give your most today to the thing I'm
here trying to make a video for you guys
I'm trying to bring the best that I've
got today that I have on this day for
this video
are you proud of yourself
when you go to sleep tonight are you
proud of yourself I gave my best today
because if you are impatient with
yourself and your effort every single
day that's a fast track to actually
getting the results you're after flip
your patients and impatience and number
three is think big act small
you gotta think big and act small you
have a big Gene big mission big Vision
something that you're trying to
accomplish and it's going to change the
world and it's amazing and you're so
excited and being Visionaries is what
makes us entrepreneurs so amazing right
I love your big dream
but sometimes that big dream is too big
and then you you feel like you can't do
it unless you have venture capital and
you have a team and you've quit your job
and all these things have lined up that
stuff is never going to line up that's
the problem and then it's five years
later and you still haven't done
anything on it meanwhile dummies are
winning off of your idea just because
they started and so you need to act
small you think big and you act small
you have this big dream big Vision
amazing and then what are you gonna do
right now today what's the smallest
possible easiest simplest way to just
build momentum because that's the thing
that's missing for most entrepreneurs
momentum you don't have enough momentum
you're a genius you have great ideas
you're Michael Jordan all of this stuff
can work out it's a beautiful business a
beautiful world you're gonna make but
there's no momentum behind it because
you're not doing enough every day
because you're thinking too big and
you're not acting enough so think big
and act small rule number four take your
shot when I was 20 years old I missed my
shot because I was scared and I vowed
never to do it again I was in Paris I
was on vacation I was in university and
I'm sitting here with my map outside
your Notre Dame cathedral in Paris and a
girl comes up and asks me for directions
but she was a French girl
and it didn't twig until later that why
would a French Grill be asking me for
directions
in English
didn't really make sense right and then
I thought you know what I should ask her
out if you see what she's doing tonight
should take her to you know ask her out
for coffee or dinner or something see
what she's up to but I was afraid I was
afraid to do it I was afraid to do it
and I let her walk away because really
was I was afraid of rejection and As
She's Walking Away the Notre Dame is on
a river and I'm on one side of the river
as she crosses over to the other side of
the river
and I was so upset at myself I was so
upset that I didn't take my shot I was
so upset that I didn't try at least try
and what I did was ended up taking a
picture
and as I took the picture she actually
walked behind one of the market stalls
and I didn't actually get her picture
it's fine so I had this beautiful
picture of this French you know
Riverside and what I did when I got home
I was still upset about it so I blew the
picture up and I put it on my wall I was
actually trying to find the picture to
show you guys but I couldn't find
anywhere in my files I blew it up though
and I put it in my wall so I'm in
University I blow it up and put on my
wall everybody who walks in
ask me about the picture
and it just looks like a nice beautiful
French scene but I didn't tell anybody
what it really represented to me why it
was really so important and I looked at
that picture every day because the next
time that I had to take my shot I wanted
to go out and do it I didn't want to be
afraid I wanted to conquer my fear and
say yes
and this served me really well a year or
so later when I had to make
the really tough decision do I take this
job that I always wanted I had these
high paying job opportunities 80 100 000
starting salary with the companies that
I really wanted to go at or continue
with my startup that was failing I was
making 300 a month The Logical practical
safe easy thing to do would have been to
take the job it's what I thought I
always wanted so my friends want is what
you're supposed to do coming out of
University I didn't want to live with
the regret of not knowing what happened
with my business and looking at that
picture daily reminded me to take my
shot the next time it comes around and
so I gave myself a year to say
I'm going to push off those jobs they'll
still be there in a year even if it's
not those jobs it's some other job I'm
going to give this a shot I can deal
with the failure I can deal with the
rejection I can deal with that not
working out even though that's a really
kind of short-term intense pain when I
can't deal with is the regret of not
knowing because that's not some
short-term minimal pain that's forever
if I chose not to focus on my business
and I took that job I would forever look
back on that moment and think
what if
what if I just tried a little bit harder
what if I gave it a little bit more yeah
you know but it wasn't working I wasn't
getting results but what if I gave it a
little bit more I did not want to live
with that regret and I'm sure you've had
moments in your life too when you didn't
take the shot when you had an
opportunity right in front of you
and you didn't go for it like Eminem
says if you had one shot one opportunity
to seize everything you ever wanted
would you take it
and that picture on the wall helped me
take my shot
and I hope sincerely
that the next time you get your chance
at something that you don't shrink down
that you don't say no out of fear that
you don't say no because you find some
practical reason why you can't do it
that you take your shot and if you've
had those moments that you regret
where you wanted to take your shot and
you didn't
give yourself a visual reminder like I
did in my room
to say this
is not happening again
next time
I'm going to take my shot
I hope you take yours rule number five
the last one before our very special
bonus clip make your decisions you need
to make the big decisions in your life
with your heart and the small ones with
your head this is where so many
entrepreneurs fall down this is where so
many entrepreneurs make mistakes because
you see a trend you see an opportunity
you see something that makes sense it
just makes sense on paper it's so clear
that it's gonna happen but if it doesn't
energize you if you don't love it if
it's not in your heart just tame it I
can't wait to go off and do that thing
you're never gonna win you're never
gonna win because you're going up
against people who love it you're going
up against people who love it who
breathe it who sleep it who dream about
it and for you it's just an opportunity
you're never gonna win big look at all
your Heroes all your mentors people you
look up to the people who've done it
it's like I want to be like this person
in my field I want to be I want to do it
like she did it like she did it they
love doing the thing they love doing the
thing doing it gives them energy
I look at what I do I'm here in Dallas
I'm about to speak at video marketing
World an annual Summit of some of the
top creators on YouTube to help share
give back help the community give
feedback Train on YouTube I love doing
this stuff
what am I I'm in the parking lot filming
videos for you guys not because it's a
strategy not because I need to make a
video a day because I love it this this
is this is the best I'm about to go into
this meeting to this conference and I'm
gonna hang out with entrepreneurs all
day long from the time I get in there
until whatever time am I'm gonna be
hanging out with entrepreneurs and
helping them with their business helping
them with their Channel because I love
it
and if that sounds exhausting for you
amazing don't do it and if it sounds
energizing for you yes go and do it you
need to make the big decisions with your
heart and then your head's still
important it's like don't lose it's not
the message is not don't listen to Logic
the message is not don't look for
opportunities it's look for
opportunities within the thing that you
love
right if if I love making videos and I
love making content and I love helping
entrepreneurs but I went all in on
MySpace right now I'm gonna lose it's
not the right strategy right you need
both it's working hard plus working
smart it's following what you love doing
plus chasing opportunities but what
takes precedence what's the most
important thing your heart the energy if
you are saying oh man Monday if that's
your mindset around Monday you're doing
the wrong thing you're in the wrong
career you're in the wrong business you
will never be the top player in your
industry it'll never happen for you if
that's your mindset
if you're itching to get back to it if
you can't wait to go to that meeting
can't wait to code can't wait to make
that piece of art can't wait to go and
make that video can't wait to sit down
and write lyrics for your next song if
that's the thing
then you're gonna be successful it's not
going to be easy it's still the long
road it's still a path you still have to
put in the grind and the effort and use
strategies to help you get there faster
but it has to start by doing things that
are energizing to you you're going to
spend so much time working guys you're
gonna spend so much time working as an
entrepreneur
why not do stuff that makes you come
alive why not do stuff that gives you
energy
and so I want you to get out of your
head I want you to stop making decisions
first from your head I want you to stop
making decisions only because it's going
to help you get some goal a short-term
thinking and you're never going to win
doing it big decisions with the heart
big decisions that give you energy look
at your calendar are you energized about
the week that's coming up
look at your account go load your
calendar right now load it on your
computer a little on your phone however
you're loading you can't look at it look
at your calendar look at the week ahead
are you excited
are you excited about what you're about
to do if not you're doing the wrong
stuff
if you're only excited about 10 of your
calendar
you're only pouring your Genius your
Michael Jordan level Talent into 10 of
your time you're not gonna get to where
you want to go you need to flip it
even if it doesn't make practical sense
at the beginning
because all great things are made from
the heart all great things every great
business every great song every great
creation
started from here from a place of
passion from place of purpose from place
of energy
and I want to put some pressure on you
guys to go off and Chase it down because
so many entrepreneurs fail
and they lose a lot of money
it's not
an easy game but one of the biggest
reasons if not the number one reason is
because people picking in the street
people pick a business idea solely
because they're chasing an opportunity
down and they didn't love doing the work
you have to love the work you have to
love the work
stepping into my schedule should be
torture for you and me stepping into
your schedule should be torture for me I
shouldn't be able to last a day in your
schedule because I hate it so much for
you it's juice you love it
so look at that week look at your week
ahead
and if you're not pumped for it at least
for 80 of it you're not gonna love every
single moment of every single day but if
you're not pumped for at least 80 of
your calendar what's ahead you need to
sit down and decide to make a major
change in how you're living your life
and run your business
because you're never going to make
anything great
if you have a calendar full of low
energy decisions
the mind is getting in your own way if
you want to lose weight you know how to
do it you got to eat less you got to
work out more you will lose weight why
are you not doing it self-discipline
your mind is getting in your way what I
see self-discipline as a positive I I
think self-discipline has a really
negative connotation a lot of a lot of
times I think
people are putting out it comes across
as this really negative thing like you
have to force yourself to do all of the
stuff that you really hate and it's
gonna suck but you have to keep going
you got to do it you got to be
disciplined if you're not disciplined
you suck everything's terrible it just
comes across at this really negative
forcing yourself to do stuff that
doesn't resonate with me I see
self-discipline as a really positive
thing I think it's really helpful I
think it's amazing and beautiful and
golden let's look at weight as an
example I am the lowest weight that I've
been all year I'm on a routine it's
working the specific strategies that
don't really matter one intermittent
fasting so I'll only have water and a
coffee until noon and then after that
I'll start eating I do that seven days a
week I run for 30 minutes uh usually at
night while I'm watching the show with
my wife seven days a week and then six
days a week I'll restrict my calories
not really forcing myself not to eat
food just not eating Doritos and not
eating junk right eating healthy food
six days a week and then Saturdays I get
to do what I want six days a week those
are the strategies that I use
it may seem like torture but it's not
and the thing that helps me get through
it is the mindset because the positive
of all of this is I'm losing weight I'm
feeling great I'm making progress I'm
I'm super pumped that I'm getting closer
to my goal I feel amazing about myself
so I think self-discipline usually it
seems to focus just on the actions that
you just have to grind your way through
it without enough focus on the mission
of what you're trying to accomplish and
how beautiful and wonderful that is and
so yes some of it might suck right but
you're moving towards something amazing
and beautiful so I think people just
focus too much on the negative part of
it and and if you force yourself to do
something that you hate you can only do
it for so long before you give up if you
can't tie it into the bigger picture of
what you're trying to accomplish then
you will give up and you will quit and
you will feel terrible and then I think
having other people yell at you but how
you need to have self-discipline doesn't
actually help I think it actually makes
it worse because you develop the
identity for yourself of I don't have
any self-discipline you can build it
it's not that difficult to do in my
perspective in my view all you need to
do is make sure that you have a really
strong why make sure that you have a an
outcome that you are really looking
forward to and you love doing and then
the process itself how do you make the
process as enjoyable as possible
how do you make the process just not
absolutely suck every single day going
in right if you figure that out then you
win
[Music]
it this far in the video I want to
celebrate you most people start and
don't finish most people never actually
follow through most people say they want
something but they don't ever do the
work to actually get it but you're
different you are special believe Nation
you made it here all the way to the end
and I love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome and if you
want to watch Evan's top 10 rules for
Success check out the video next to me I
think you can enjoy continue to believe
I will see you there the next Evan is on
the other side of even more belief
self-belief comes from doing difficult
things so the more that you do something
that you didn't think you're capable of
doing all of a sudden you say oh I can't
do it every time there's something hard
in front of you that then you